An interesting statistic with Malawi is
that its forests are being stripped of
its soft pine because of the amount of
coffins that are being made because of
aids related deaths.
So,
you know,
you just expect this place to be sort of
gutted and sort of just an inferno of
misery.
But it was the act opposite.
Um,
I,
one day the longs that,
that the end of the story is because the
beginning of the story is long,
but I got lost and I was walking on the
side of a road in Malawi.
My cell phone didn't work.
I really had no idea where I was.
My,
my guide or the person who was driving
me didn't know where I was.
And I'm sure to some of the people who
were driving past it must've looked
quite strange to see what they call,
I believe I'm,
I'm deemed Emma Zuniga there,
which means white person on the side of
the road.
Um,
and I kept on walking and I got to this
gas station and I asked,
could someone help me please?
I don't know where I am.
Um,
I don't even know how to make a phone
call to where I'm supposed to get back
to.
And this woman who worked there came up
to me and she said,
I can help you,
would you like to use my phone,
which was probably expensive for her.
And she found,
she helped me get back to where I needed
to go.
But as I was waiting for someone to pick
me up,
uh,
they,
she said,
what are you doing here?
And I said,
I'm here doing stories about HIV aids
and women and women in Malawi.
And she said,
I'm one of them.
And we formed this,
this unusual friendship,
you know,
and that was like an experience that
really like kind of as a,
those people that you meet that kind of
changed your life.
Like here was this woman who works seven
days a week,
is a single mother.
Um,
she finds out while I'm there that her
daughter is positive and she's
supporting her family,
her perspective husband gave her the
illness and is outs and laughter and
it's out spreading this illness as well
among other women.
But yeah,
at this woman is the most graceful woman
I've ever met and the most dignified
woman I've ever met.
And
yeah,
was so lonely because she couldn't talk
about her status.
But in spite of that,
just exuded such warmth and such
kindness and
you know,
it was really meeting her.
You really saw the dichotomy of how cold
her reality was,
but this beautiful heart that existed in
all of this and the grace that she
existed in,
in.